all right hello everyone today we're
going to look at andre karpathy's
cvpr talk about full self-driving mode
in tesla and what tesla's been
doing to push that beyond its current
state so let's just say that autonomous
driving is a hard problem
you have to control a car and pretty
much anything could happen however we're
able to teach it to pretty much any
human
on the planet so the problem is
definitely solvable now the current
stack they have
for full self-driving or that they
intended to use it seems like is what
they call
sensor fusion which is where you take a
bunch of different signals like
camera signals and radar signals and so
on and you try to
fuse their signals together this kind of
works it seems but it runs into problems
such as what do you do when the
different sensors disagree
and it turns out solving that problem is
quite hard and that's why
tesla apparently is transitioning to a
fully
only vision stack everything is going to
be
vision based in tesla full self driving
now today we're going to look at the
best and important bits of the talk
right here
now absolutely invite you to go watch
the entire talk if you're interested it
is enjoyable in full length and it is on
youtube
andre gives a lot of good examples here
and the amount of
effort that went into engineering this
into collecting the data
how this is deployed is astounding now
keep in mind
this is the lead ai scientist for tesla
so it is going to be a bit of an ad
however it is pretty cool to see that we
are actually
making a real push towards full self
driving
a lot of people have been super salty
saying that elon musk has promised this
like
one or two years ago already but come on
i mean
do you see anyone else doing fully
self-driving at this level
no so shut up so the first thing right
here is a couple of scenarios of what
tesla is already doing which is sort of
a driver assistance
so if the person is driving but the
system is relatively sure that the
person's making a mistake
the system kicks in mostly to do
automatic braking
for the user so i just i want to show
you this one example right here
you start slow and probably you know
does not actually enter the intersection
uh these are examples from pedal
misapplication
mitigation pmm here a person is
unparking from their driving spot and
they are trying to turn and then they
mess up and they accidentally floor it
so they floor it right there so you see
like the person
wanted to break but stepped on the gas
there are people right in front of the
car so be salty all you want
this right here is already worth it so
as a human there is a lot of resistance
against fully self-driving feeling that
you're no longer in control anymore but
the matter of the fact is that these
systems already
are and in the near future will be even
much more
better than humans at driving it's going
to be
much cleaner much safer much faster less
traffic jams and so on to let the
machines take over the driving
pretty much in the same way as it's much
safer to let the machines take over the
braking
in these scenarios the only times you're
actually going to drive by hand
is when you do it for fun now i drive a
motorbike it's a lot of fun to drive
but in a car especially with other
people
or if i do it for work if i may be a
little bit tired
machines all the way so the full
self-driving beta
is rolled out to a small handful of
customers
right now and they do upload youtube
videos every now and then
of what they're doing and it seems to
work fairly
fairly well apparently they have had no
crashes
so far while driving about 1.7 million
miles
in full stealth driving you can see on
the screen in the middle right here
that the predictions that the system
gives is pretty good
though we've also seen some other
predictions that are
not so good throughout youtube like
there's this one video where the truck
in front of the car
has street lights on its back and the
car just keeps thinking
it's kind of red lights however we don't
know if this is the legacy stack
or not and if the car would actually
break since the
lights are not on red but it's been a
scare going around youtube for a little
bit so here andre shows a video of
weimo already doing this much earlier
than tesla having sort of an
automatic car drive around an
intersection and so on this
works if you're in a really defined zone
let's say a city that you know that you
have accurate maps for this does not
work if
you want to do this anywhere in the
world
to do this anywhere in the world you
need to rely on the car
itself that means you need a lot of data
so the data that this new system gets
is just vision it's eight cameras around
the car
and that's it and andre makes a good
case here that that is actually
all you need humans are able to navigate
from this
and cars should be able to do the same
so an absolutely necessary ingredient to
train such a system is a good clean
label data set
if you just wanted to use humans to
annotate every single frame
of cars driving around that would
probably be prohibitively expensive even
for
tesla so they came up with what i think
is a pretty cool
method called auto labeling now i'm sure
they're not the inventors of this system
but
to use it on this scale is very smart
and it works out pretty nicely of course
we
need uh to collect training a typical
approach might be to use humans to
annotate cars around us in three
dimensions what we found actually works
really well
is an auto labeling approach so it's not
your humans just like annotating cars
it's an offline tracker as we call it
and it's an auto labeling process for
collecting data at the scale that is
necessary so we need to get millions of
hard examples so this is where the scale
comes from is that it's not labeled
early by humans although humans are
involved it's labeled automatically so
here's an example of some automatic
labels we were able to drive four cars
on the highway and the way you do this
is because you are offline and you are
trying to just annotate a club you have
a large number of benefits that you
don't typically have if you're at test
time under strict latency requirements
in the car so you can take your time to
fully figure out exactly all the objects
in what they are you can use neural
networks that are extremely heavy they
are not deployable for various reasons
you can use benefit of hindsight because
you know the future not just the path
you can use all kinds of expensive
offline optimization and tracking
techniques
you can use extra sensors in this case
for example actually radar was one of
the sensors that we used for the auto
labeling but there's actually a massive
difference between using radar at test
time and using it in the offline traffic
point here is that
if you record data and you're trying to
figure out at
inference time like while you're driving
what's happening it's a lot harder
than if you have the same data but kind
of at home
in the lab so what you want to do is you
want to drive around and just record
not even not predict or anything just
record data record from all your sensors
you can even stick expensive sensors on
the cars where you collect the data
and then you take all that data and you
use the biggest
heaviest processors you have to figure
out what actually happened during that
time
what he mentions here is the benefit of
hindsight which means that
if you're in a car and you're driving
and all of a sudden
something obscures your vision you will
be
sort of lost because all you have okay
you can maybe guess
that a car in front of you is still
there but who knows they might
turn or something now if you record the
whole video sequence
you're able to see what happens beyond
the obstruction of vision
and if you see the car is still there
you can make a good inference
that the car was actually there the
whole time and therefore you can
annotate that data with a label saying
hey that car was there the whole time
you can also
do active learning and shell out to
actual human annotators what you're not
sure about so this benefit of hindsight
is really important here when you're
under the time constraint of not being
able to see into the future
as well as the latency constraint and
you have to have like an efficient
neural network
in the lab you don't have any of this
the method here if you're
developing something real time i mean
this might seem obvious to you
i found it to be pretty cool yes record
then figure out what happened
then use that as a labeled data set
so here's an example of how such a
persistent track
would look like after the neural network
has been trained on data like this
here's some examples of really tricky
scenarios i don't actually know exactly
what this is but basically this car
drops a bunch of debris on us and we
maintain a consistent track for the
label and of course if you have millions
of labels like this the neural net if
it's a
powerful enough neural net will actually
end up learning to persist these tracks
in these kinds of scenarios here's
another example
there's a car in front of us i actually
am not 100 sure what happens in this
case but
as you'll see there's some kind of a
dust cloud that develops here and
briefly occludes the car
but in the auto labeling tool we are
able to persist this track because we
saw it before and we saw it after so we
can actually stitch it up
and use it as a training set for the
neural net so that's how they get
clean labels in an automatic or
semi-automatic way but they still need
to get a lot of data
from kind of edge cases because most of
driving is quite uneventful
straight driving and was done 40 years
ago or something like this
i think schmidt uber in gtc 21 talk
talked about
autonomous cars on highways on
controlled stretches of highways
super duper early already so what we
really need to collect
is edge cases and for collecting these
edge cases
tesla has developed these what they call
triggers so these are kind of hand
programmed
rules of what data should go into the
annotation pipeline so imagine if
all these cars driving around not only
the people with full self-driving but
the detection the actual recording of
data is activated in all the tesla cars
driving around
they all send that data back to the
server of course that's way too much
data
and also it's very unbalanced in terms
of how many critical situations are in
there again most of it will be sort of
straight road mt just drive straight so
what they do is they
filter this data for these trigger
events
now these trigger events can be as
simple as whenever the radar and the
vision mismatch
so whenever they disagree on something
that's an interesting example but
you know it goes into very detailed such
as we detect
breaking lights but the acceleration is
positive
so with these triggers they're able to
source a diverse set of training samples
and edge cases where the neural network
can learn the tricky situations rather
than just the
long stretches of road so i think it's
safe to say that
a good mark of quality on these systems
is going to be
how well these triggers are maintained
like
how well do they represent the full
driving experience of the end users of
the cars but so far from the results we
got
it seems like they cover the road
situations fairly well
and all of them are iteration and you're
looking at what's coming back you're
tuning your trigger and you're sourcing
data from all these scenarios basically
over the last four months we've done
quite extensive data engine
we've ended up doing seven shadow modes
and seven loops around this data engine
here where on the top right is where you
begin you have some seed data set you
train your neural network on your data
set and you deploy the neural network in
the customer cars in shadow mode and the
network is silently making predictions
by the way if you if you like squint
really hard i don't know if this is just
a depiction of a neural network or if
this is
the actual architecture they're using i
don't think so
but there is like a stride of six in
there and max pooling you know
just just noting that for no particular
reason
and then you have to have some
mechanisms for sourcing inaccuracies of
the neural net you're just looking at
its predictions and then you're using
one of these triggers you're getting
these scenarios where the network is
probably misbehaving some of those let's
end up going to unit tests to make sure
that we even if we're failing right now
we make sure we pass later and in
addition those examples are being auto
labeled and incorporated into a training
set and then as asynchronous process
we're also always data cleaning the
current training
so we spin this loop over and over again
until the network basically becomes
incredibly good so in total we've done
seven rounds of shadow mode for this
release
so shadow mode is what they call when
they let the predictions run but they
don't hook them up to the control
so you're driving yourself but the
system predicts all the time and
whenever one of these trigger
happens that's an interesting data point
that it's going to send back to the
server
actually let's be honest it's probably
going to send everything back to the
server
so the data set they come up with is 1.5
petabytes
crazy so next he's going to go into the
architecture of
the neural net and this is also fairly
interesting and not entirely standard on
the top
all of them are processed by an image
extractor play the layout of the
synthetic visual cortex in order to
efficiently process this information our
architecture roughly looks like this we
have these images coming from multiple
cameras on the top all of them are
processed by an image extractor like a
backbone i think resnet kind of style
then there's a multi-cam fusion that
uses the information from all the aid to
use and this is a kind of a transformer
that we use to fuse this information and
then we fuse information first across
all the cameras and then across all of
time and that is also done either by
transformer by recurrent neural network
or just by three-dimensional
convolutions we've experimented with a
lot of kind of fusion strategies here to
get this to work really well and then
what we have afterwards after the fusion
is done is we have this branching
structure that doesn't just consist of
heads but actually we've expanded this
over the last few last years or so where
you now have heads that branch into
trunks that branch into terminals
so there's a lot of branching structure
and the reason you want this branching
structure is because there's a huge
amount of outputs that you're interested
in and you can't afford to have a single
neural network for every one of the
individual outputs you have to of course
amortize the forward pass
so this is pretty interesting the top
part here what they call the backbone is
pretty standard
if you have a video especially with
multiple cameras you want to extract
information from each frame of each
camera sort of individually
then you want to fuse that information
across all the cameras for a single time
step and then you want to fuse that
information with the information of all
the other time steps so so far
so good that sort of gives you a
representation of what happens
in these frames in these cameras during
that stretch of time however
after that usually even if you have
multiple
predictions what you would do is you
would sort of have like one prediction
head on top of that backbone however
since they are in a car and have to
decide
real fast it's not really feasible to
have sort of these
different columns for each of the
prediction tasks because
as he says they're interested in a lot
of different signals
think depth prediction which means that
for every pixel you have to provide a
depth
estimation think tracks of other cars
think
pedestrians think street lights think
okay where are their lanes at
or navigation in general so all these
signals are things to predict
and it's not good enough to have like a
separate head for each of the
predictions so what they do is they have
as you call these branching structures
where there are multiple heads yes
and within these multiple heads there
are what they call trunks and within the
trunks there are the individual like
little what they call terminals so
essentially it's a hierarchical
prediction i'm gonna guess that the
tasks that go
together sort of are grouped together so
maybe one head is for all the pixel
prediction tasks and another
head is more for that classification
tasks and then within one head you have
a trunk that deals more with like object
classification
and another trunk that deals more with
like navigation classification
and the individual terminals then do the
actual tasks this is a pretty cool way
of getting a highly performant many
output network
all together such that its size and
computational speed are still maintained
the other nice benefit of the branching
structure is that it decouples at the
terminals it decouples all these signals
so if i'm someone working on velocity
for a particular object type or
something like that i have a small piece
of neural network that i can actually
fine-tune without touching any of the
other signals and so i can work in
isolation to some extent and actually
get something to work pretty well and
then once in a while so basically the
iteration scheme is that a lot of people
are fine-tuning and once you know you
just gotta imagine the ml ops behind
this
it's like hey uh where do you deploy
your models i do it on
kubernetes i have uh ml flow oh no i i
use the tensorflow extended yeah it's
pretty cool
what do you do car i deploy
on car so next uh
is going into this in-house
supercomputer that they built or
are building and this is a massive thing
absolutely massive
he says that in terms of flops it's
something like the fifth biggest
computer
in the world its storage speed is
incredible so i'm pretty sure you could
even actually render far cry 2 on this
thing
maybe but in total it has 5 760 gpus not
any gpus the most expensive
a 180 gigabyte gpus
it would be interesting to see what kind
of algorithms they use
on top of this uh to actually do the
distributed training or
whether it's all just kind of simple
data parallelism aggregating gradients
and so on of course they have super fast
interconnect super fast storage super
fast everything
and it looks sweet like is this a stock
photo
of a server room or is this the actual
server room this effort basically is
incredibly vertically integrated in the
ai team so as i showed you we own the
vehicle in the sensing and we source our
own data and we annotate our own data
and we train our on-prem cluster and
then we deploy all of the neural
networks that we train on our in-house
developed chip so we have the fsd
computer
here that has two socs has the chips
here and they have our own custom
npu neural processing unit here at
roughly 36 times each
so these chips are specifically designed
for the neural networks that we want to
run
for yeah i mean this is the dream right
if you're
an ai professional owning the whole
pipeline is going to boost your
productivity
by so much you're not bound by the
constraint of
anything other than the limits on the
final system which
is a car so fairly difficult but in
between of that you have control over
everything you have control over how the
data is collected
annotated you have control over where it
is deployed to on what architecture of
chip because you make the chip
so i guess the lesson is if you're
looking to change the world you better
own
a good chunk of it so now it's going to
show some examples of what this new
vision only stack could do remember they
used to do
fusion of sensors which means they
essentially have radar they have vision
maybe some other sensors and they try to
integrate this information from all
of the sensors they compare this to the
new vision based system now check out
what happens
in terms of the depth and velocity
predictions that we're able to achieve
by putting all these pieces together and
training these networks at scale so the
first example here i have a video where
this is on track testing so this is an
engineering car
and we asked it to slam on the brakes as
hard as it possibly can so this is a
very harsh braking here in front of us
even though it doesn't look like that
in the videos it's very harsh breaking
so what you can see on the right here is
you can see the outputs from the legacy
stack which had radar vision fusion and
from the new stack which is vision alone
in blue so in the orange legacy stack
you can actually see these uh track
drops here when the car was breaking
really harshly and basically the issue
is that the braking was so harsh that
the radar stack that we have
actually ended up not associating car
and dropping the track and then
reinitializing it all the time and so
it's as if the vehicle disappeared and
reappeared like six times during the
period of this breaking and so this
created a bunch of artifacts here but we
see that the new stack in blue is
actually
not subject to this behavior at all it
just gives a clean signal in fact here
there's no smoothing i believe on the
blue signal here this is the raw depth
and velocity that comes out from the
neural net the final neuron that we
released with about three weeks ago and
you can see that it's fairly smooth here
and of course you could go
into the radar stack and you could you
know adjust the height parameters of the
tracker like why is it dropping
tracks and so on but then you are
spending engineering efforts and focus
on a stack
that is like not really barking up the
right tree and so it's better to again
just focus on the vision and make it
work really well
and we see that it is much more robust
when you train it at scale
so there you have it proof by one
example that the new thing works better
isn't that every cvpr paper ever
but no in in any case i can totally
believe that the new stack
even though it drops a bunch of the
sensors is better
because ultimately if your one sensor if
vision is so
performant that in every single
disagreement you go with the vision
thing then
why do you have the other sensors at all
the thing in front of it is just
kind of breaking too fast so the radar
kind of loses it and then regains it and
loses it and regains it now i have no
idea
how radar works so i'm speaking from
complete ignorance right here but what
i'm going to
guess as far as i understand it is that
radar just kind of gives you
the velocities of stuff in front of you
and then there is a tracking
algorithm on top of radar that tries to
figure out which stuff
is the same stuff and this is very much
what they do
in this auto labeling where they have
sort of a track on something right and
then they use hindsight and then they
have a tracking algorithm that decides
which things are the same even though we
don't see them all the time
and here you can clearly see the benefit
of shifting this
from inference time which is what you
have to do
with radar to the training time which is
what you can do with vision so you can
teach the vision system
to sort of do this persistent tracking
whereas the radar system you have to
hand
tune it to do this in real time now it
makes the point that of course you could
go
into the radar system change the hyper
parameters but then he says why
bark up the wrong tree why waste time on
a stack that isn't functioning well it's
a bit of a chicken and an egg problem
right if you were to put as much effort
into the radar stack as you were into
the vision system
i'm going to guess that these results
would go away
and that it's able to keep up maybe but
arguments
for going vision only is a strong one
and i don't doubt
that it is probably a good way forward
and basically what's happening here is
that the radar is very trigger-happy and
it sees all these false stationary
objects everywhere like everything that
like sticks out is a stationary target
and radar by itself doesn't know what
actually is a stationary car and what
isn't so it's waiting for vision to
associate with it and vision if it's not
held up to a high enough bar is noisy
and contributes sort of error and the
sensor fusion stack just kind of like
picks it up too late so again you could
fix all that even though it's a very
gross
system with a lot of if statements and
so on because the sensor fusion is
complicated because the error modes for
vision and radar are slightly are quite
different but here when we just work
with vision alone and we take out the
radar
vision recognizes this object very early
gives the correct depth and velocity and
there's no issues so we actually get an
initial slow down much earlier and
we've really like simplified the stack a
lot yeah so here you can see the
same failure mode in vision that it kind
of gets a track but doesn't but get a
track but doesn't
the important part is that once you get
closer to the object it is
fairly consistent right as you can see
right here the vision stack recognizes
this
truck on the side much earlier than the
radar stack did now again
this might just be a function of the
hyper parameters used i'm sure you could
just lower the threshold for the radar
but you'd run
into different problems now during the
queue and day he makes a
good point in that yes other sensors
would be nice to have
but just the pure economics speak in
favor of vision 2. like
we develop cameras with much more rigor
as a society than we do radar systems
and therefore
the camera sensors are just so much
better nowadays and cheaper
so you can afford to build many of them
into all kinds of things and collect
data
and make your systems better through
that than to put kind of a lidar on top
of a car
and having to sort of fuse those signals
with the visual signals especially when
they're in conflict with one another so
if you ask me
i'm a fan i like what i see here even
though i know it's kind of an ad i don't
own a tesla but i think it's still
pretty cool so in the end they talks a
bit about what they do to validate this
data
and how they roll it out and gives a
bunch of more
examples of tracking and there's a q a
at the end so if you are interested in
that i
absolutely welcome you to go watch the
entire talk it is on youtube and that
was it for me
i hope you enjoyed this and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
ciao